[Music]
it's amazing how people can't
differentiate between say the narrow AI
that you know allows a car to figure out
what a lane line is and and and you know
and navigate streets versus general
intelligence like these are just very
different things like your toaster and
your computer or both machines but once
much more sophisticated than another
you're confident with Tesla you can
create the world's best toaster world's
best toaster yes but with the world's
best self-driving I'm I yes I do to me
right now this seems game set match I
don't know I mean that's how I almost be
complacent overconfident but that's what
it appears that is just literally what
it how it appears right now I could be
wrong but it appears to be the case that
Tesla is vastly ahead of everyone
you